takehiko nakao in the imposing festival
in Frankfurt this is where the president
of the asian development bank wants to
hold the organization's annual meeting
and he knows exactly what he wants but
the general speaking guy I feel it's
better to make this way yeah next spring
3,000 financial experts bankers and
entrepreneurs will convene here to
discuss urgent issues of economic
development in Asia the bank rarely
meets outside Asia but Frankfurt is an
appropriate venue Germany is a major
contributor it's a good opportunity for
German government to show the examples
of sustainable development and good are
my decisions and and also how employment
can be enhanced through good education
training the adb's most recent focus is
climate change the organization wants to
invest six billion dollars in
environmental projects more than double
its previous efforts the goal is to
mitigate existing damage and prevent
further problems yeah because asia and
pacific keys are in a sense a very
crucial region for these policies of
addressing climate change first of all
they are very susceptible to climate
ready disaster like a typhoon high level
of the sea in Frankfurt the bank wants
to convince private investors to support
it with much-needed capital the ADB
estimates that 800 billion dollars a
year are required to fund the
infrastructure needs of Asia and the
Pacific for the coming decade